First up,
he is the governor of Florida,
who is--
Wow! Currently on our show?
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
...currently running
to be the Republican nominee
for president in 2024,
Governor Ron DeSantis!
(AUDIENCE CHEERS, APPLAUDS)
-Hey!
-What's up, man?
-Ron.
-How are you doing?
That's a pretty dark blue state
right there.
I know, I know.
Welcome back.
That's not bad.
All right.
On a scale of nine to ten,
what'd you think
of my monologue?
Honestly, I was laughing.
-I'll give you that.
-Right?
Laughing on both sides of
the aisle too, so it was good.
And welcome back to the show.
I know you guys
were on hiatus for a while.
Oh, thank you.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
(CHUCKLES) Yes.
I-- I do gotta put in a plug.
Like, if you ever have problems
in California,
you know, in Florida,
not only do we have
no income tax,
no vax mandates allowed
in the state of Florida.
Well, we're gonna get to that.
We're gonna get to that.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
I know. But people do
wear cowboy boots with a suit.
-RON DESANTIS: That's right.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
So, I'm not going to Florida.
Okay? That's--
That's just a crazy thing.
We're proud of it.
But there were no cowboys
in Florida, Ron.
No, yeah.
You should try Florida.
We're one of the top
cattle states in America.
-BILL MAHER: Really?
-Once you go from the beach,
you go to the interior Florida,
nothing but cattle ranches.
Oh, all right.
Well, I-- (CHUCKLES)
I stand corrected.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Because I'm wearing
orthopedic shoes.
There you go.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Okay, so the debate.
It was a shit show.
But I-- Right?
I mean, even you said
you wouldn't have--
you would have turned it off
if you were watching.
I mean, people screaming
over each other.
I couldn't hear what
any of them were saying.
It was terrible.
But I heard you won.
I heard the polling
said you won.
-What did you win? With--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
No, honestly.
With Trump not in the race,
what did you win?
Well, but I think that,
you know,
he-- he's not showing up,
he's missing in action.
He owes it to voters
to show up
and defend his record.
And I think he thinks
he can take a juiced poll
and then people
don't get to vote.
That's not the way
the system works.
You gotta go earn votes.
So I'm showing up,
I'm showing that--
And that's--
Here's the thing.
In the midst of all the show
that happened,
I was the one guy
that people said,
"You know what?
This guy's actually acting
like a president,"
when the rest were not.
And so, okay, there I am.
I told Donald,
"Let's do a debate."
I'm debating your governor,
-Gavin Newsom, soon.
-BILL: We're gonna get to that.
But let's do a debate
with me and him.
-I'll do it.
-BILL: Okay. All right.
But this--
Can I ask you one thing
about these debates?
Can you get rid of this guy,
Doug Burgum?
(LAUGHTER)
This guy-- (CHUCKLES)
This bugs me.
He is not gonna be president.
This guy could start dating
Taylor Swift,
no one would care.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
North Dakota, it's not
even a state. All right.
But you know, the thing is,
you did not take my advice.
What was it?
I was on this show a few times
and we talked about it.
I said, "This guy's crazy
to run this time. He's--"
-What are you, 45 years old?
-Yeah.
-You just had a birthday, right?
You could run
for the next 20 years.
If you were Biden, the next 40.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Okay, why run against Trump?
You're trying
to thread this needle
that will never happen.
Well, for a couple reasons.
You can't--
You can't disavow him,
because that's the base,
and yet you're running
against him.
And that's why--
I mean, let's face it, Ron.
If this-- If the campaign
was going well,
you wouldn't be on this show.
-Oh, that's not true.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
So, um, one, I don't think
he can win the election.
Uh, I could win the election.
Two, I don't think he could
actually get the job done
that we need to do.
For example, COVID.
I think we need accountability
for what this government did
to this country
with the COVID restrictions,
mandates, and lockdowns.
Donald Trump
is not gonna do that.
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
He says he did everything right.
He says he saved millions
of lives with lockdowns.
He claims his mRNA shots
saved 100 million lives.
He's not gonna clean house
at CDC, NIH, FDA,
or any of that.
I will do that.
I will get the job done.
And a lot of other things we do.
The one thing about me
in Florida,
and even my critics
will acknowledge,
if he says
he's gonna do something,
he will follow through
and get the job done.
So it's about the country.
Are we gonna get the country
turned around or not?
I don't think he's a vehicle
that-- that's doing it.
And-- And I have been--
When I supported him on the
things I liked, I've said it,
but I've been critical about
the things that he didn't do.
And I'll continue to do that.
Okay, but you--
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
But you campaigned for--
for election deniers in 2022.
This I do not forgive.
-Well, look--
-To quote The Godfather.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
I mean, Kari Lake,
who said Biden
is an illegitimate president,
-Trump didn't--
-Well, now she's attacking me,
so maybe I did
make a mistake there
'cause she's out there saying--
she's trying to say that
we mandated vax in Florida,
when we did the opposite.
We protected people
even from private mandates,
so-- so that may have been--
But Trump lost the election,
right?
-RON: Yeah, yeah.
-Okay, so why did you campaign
for people who said--
Because I wanted to see
Republicans win key races.
I think it's important to have--
And that's not
a deal-breaker issue for you?
That's not democracy?
Well, okay.
Well, let's go back to 2016.
Uh, you're friends in Hollywood
were cutting ads
telling the electoral college
to vote against Trump
in the electoral college
because it was stolen.
They said Russia
stole the election.
For years, they said that.
So don't act like
this is, like, a unique thing
in modern history
of the country.
-BILL: First--
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)
First of all, Ron,
I have no friends in Hollywood.